hat euch sowie mal gefallen und falls
aspekten auch auf euch zu treffen
anzeigen
leute was geht ab und herz bekommen bei
einem neuen video hier immer wieder auf
meinem channel und ja heute ist's wieder
martin dabei als wir machen heute wieder
so ein schüler video und zwar geht es
heute um die fünf dinge die jedem
schüler schon mal passiert sind alle
einfach um die fünf dinge die einfach
jeder schüler kennt ja und dann will ich
auch gar nicht lange lagern und ich
würde sagen wir fahren einfach denkt man
ich wünsche euch viel spaß oder wir
wünschen euch viel spaß und seine nummer
eins du wirst unschuldig beschuldigt
heftig antwortest du mir jetzt noch mal
die fresse einer er doch geredet er
warum die checks diese lehrer einfach
nicht nummer zwei sein mitschüler
übertreibt es ja ein ganz kleines
bisschen
nummer drei die typischen schulfilm
wunderschönen guten morgen klasse 10
heute zum grünen den abschluss des
ersten schulhalbjahres wollen wir einen
film gucken vor heimischen facto güte
nein ich ganz alexander knapp vorbei ist
auch daneben aber wir schauen uns im
film von aristo viel ist aus dem vierten
jahrhundert vor christus an und ich
schon wieder so ein scheiß er die auch
gleich zuhause bleiben können nummer
vier
dass es diese sache mit der zeit
05 du kommst von der schule nach hause
und bist einfach nur total kaputt so
leute das war's jetzt heute schon wieder
mit dem video und jahr gehofft natürlich
es hat euch gefallen und falls diese
dinge auch auf euch zu treffen
dann zeigt uns dass so einfach meinen
daumen nach oben daraus kann ich dann
auch gleich schließen dass es euch
gefallen hat oder wir können daraus
schließen dass euch gefallen hat und ja
last auf meinen kommentar da und wir
haben ja gar nicht zu sagen so leute und
jetzt muss ich natürlich am ende des
videos doch auf meinen letzten videos
aufmerksam machen auf die in fall geht
jetzt hier unten links weiter mit meinem
netz mio das war so ein kleines
nachträgliches weihnachtsgeschenk spiel
wenn ihr da noch mitmachen wollt und
eine itunes karte oder eine google plate
hatte abstauben wollt dann klickt auf
jeden fall mal drauf und macht mit und
hier unten rechts mit meinem vorletzten
video ja damit meine freundin in
ziemlich kurzer zeit geschminkt das ist
eigentlich auch ganz witzig geworden
also einfach mal bei ist abdecken und in
der video beschreibung findet ihr
natürlich noch links du instagram skfm
und facebook wenn ihr nichts mehr
verpassen wollt dann abonniere einfach
meinen kanal und ja ansonsten habe ich
euch an jetzt ist er sogar der erste
januar ich hoffe ihr hattet den schönen
rutsch ins neue jahr und drei leute